fais-le
[musique]
Si ce mélange est brisé alors le tout est au dessus.
Court, à deux ou trois kilomètres d'ici
Mais il semblait que Pura avait été frappé par la tige et que tout le monde
il y a eu un tremblement dans la terre
Et après cela, il y a un élément force eau et
Peu importe la quantité de matière première qu'il y avait avec lui
je vais commencer à donner ça
[musique]
fais-le
Présentation de la Coupe du monde contre vous
Fever Power Corporation Limited a vu la mort
Comprenez que vous ne l'avez jamais vu auparavant, mais
Jor Prasad Sah le suit
La vérification n'a pas pu le sauver dans la rivière Sita
et quand tu es dans la société
[musique]
Après être resté assis ici pendant une heure, le son est sorti
Sortez, sortez, avons-nous pensé, je ne sais pas.
Est-ce que tu nous aimes un peu avec la perte de cheveux
L'eau allait atteindre au moins un pied.
Seevi
Je t'ai tellement dit que j'ai une seconde vie
Je suis très nerveux, il y a quelques bandages en dessous.
coincé à l'intérieur du tunnel
Ici, il y a de la gouvernance mais
Il n'y a pas de machines ici
[musique]
qu'un
fais-le
[musique]
Est arrivé
qu'un